welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Miss Marvel has finally graced us
with her marvelous new Purple heartlight
powers in her new series on the
disneyplusman.org as Kamala Khan's
debuted episode shows us how these super
interesting Cosmic Bengals manifest
Powers just in time for Kamala to save
Instagram's Messiah Zoe from being
murdered by a man-made mjolnir but where
the hell did these Bangles even come
from anyway let us speculate on the
possibilities together my nerd babies
but speaking of marvelous things you can
find a bunch of cool Marvel stuff over
at New rockstarsmerch.com and not just
marvel we got Marvel Star Wars DC and
our newest latest Obsession shirt
inspired by Obi-Wan and also we have a
new one inspired by Miss Marvel should
be up right now so head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to pick some stuff up
today because we got some cool [ __ ]
alright so guys I have a feeling that
these Bengals are definitely alien and
nature because check this out in the
first episode of Miss Marvel we learned
that the Bengals actually come from
Kamala Khan's Nani or Grandma who
suspiciously sends them in the mail for
her curious granddaughter to pick up and
find and maybe put on during some type
of superhero cosplay contest after
leaving some rainbow gloves that a
friend zoned Boy made for her in the
bathroom because you know grandmas
always be prepared for any situation but
then after Kamala puts those Bengals on
for the first time we see her fall into
this weird trippy reality with a bunch
of shadowy figures with glowing eyes
watching in the background before
quickly snapping back to reality just in
time to snap ant-man's neck and then his
head or older out and almost killed a
bunch of eubes however after Kamala
crashes into the ground to enter this
weird plane of existence as these people
in the background stare at Kamala
wearing what I'm assuming to be
traditional Pakistani clothing you know
sort of like all those people walking
together on that dirt path in the Miss
Marvel trailer which makes me believe
that what we have seen in this episode
is yet another example of a plane of
untethered Consciousness in the MCU
which the most recent MCU series Moon
Knight further expanded upon after the
concept was first introduced to us all
of course through Ryan coogler's first
black panther film because we've got
ourselves another purple plane with
people with glowing eyes who also like
to rock the customary garbs of their
people much like King chachaka did when
he had the glowing Panther eyes before
transforming into his more traditionally
garved or Condon clothes to go hug his
son this could very well be kamala's
ancestral plane consisting of everyone
in kamala's lineage who have worn the
bracelet before was passed down to the
Next Generation much like the powers of
the heart-shaped Herb in wakanda was
essentially passed down from one
generation of t'challa's family to the
next now this all being said and seeing
how kamala's skin glows purple
underneath right after she puts on the
Bengals for the first time much like
t'challa skin does when he enters the
wakandan ancestral plane and knowing
that the heart-shaped herb itself that
grants the powers of the Black Panther
come from a great big blue-glowing
meteor in the ground that struck MCU
Earth thousand of years ago there is a
bit of a possibility that these Bengals
came from the very same vibranium meteor
possibly alongside when was 10 Rings you
know that other MCU Relic that gave blue
glowing powers and has a strong
connection to the alien dragons of both
the comic and live-action media
universes because in the Marvel Comics
of course the 10 rings come to the
Mandarin's position after falling from a
mcluhan spaceship and the mcluhans are
of course a race of alien dragons within
the Marvel Comics where the Alien dragon
of thing Fang Foom originally comes from
and much like when Wu won to pass the
title rings onto his son shung Chi when
he was strong enough to wield them
kamala's Nani was likely making sure her
family's connection to this Cosmic
artifact stayed intact but we cannot
forget about the original Source
material people and I'm sure that the
gang at Marvel Studios didn't either
because there is also the chance that
these Bengals could for sure be Cree in
origin as the cree rays are pretty much
responsible for Miss Marvel in the first
place in the comics for UC a long time
ago the comic book Cree came to Earth
during the course of Humanity's
Evolution and experimented on them you
know sort of like the comic book
celestials did but like a little bit
after celestials came which allowed for
the off-branch super powered inhuman
race to form when those who carried that
special Regine inside of them were
transformed after contact with the
inhuman teragen Mist a term that was of
course first recently introduced in the
MCU and Multiverse of Madness when
introducing Black Bolt as he is The
Keeper of the cree terrigen myths as the
loud ass King of the Inhumans now while
I do not believe that these Bengals
directly use the technology of the green
Cree terrorism I think that there is a
strong potential that the entire Khan
family on kamala's mother's side to have
an incredibly strong inhuman Gene a gene
that these Cosmic Bangles can tap into
to manifest that inhuman gene into this
new blue red and purple kind of way and
that it will only be through black
Bolt's own green terrorism that these
amazing looking Cosmic Powers will no
longer need 90s Cosmic Bengals to tap
into and manifest in Powers because
they'll then begin to manifest in their
traditional big ass fleshy human hand
kind of way like they did in the comics
and of course we cannot forget Talos
Nick Fury's line and Spider-Man far from
home about Cree sleeper cells y'all I
thought Cree having sleeper cells with
top secret information because there
could be a chance that these pre-sleeper
cells are just talos's way of saying in
humans as the Inhumans in the comics
were originally made by the cree race to
be a race of super soldiers because the
cree themselves could not evolve like
humans could so they experimented on
human people to try to make human super
soldiers to fight the skrulls because
the cree can't get along with anybody
but whether it's in the form of a
dragon-affiliated piece of technology
from a mysterious vibranium meteor or
just an inhuman biology hijacking
wristband these bracelets are for sure
mega alien in my opinion which could be
why damage control themselves feel like
capturing this Marvel is perfectly
within their purview as they were of
course first introduced as the true
chautari cleanup room in Spider-Man
homecoming like over the course of over
a decade damage control has probably
become so familiar with the way MCU
alien technology behaves and functions
since thatchitari invasion in 2012 and
so when they saw kamala's wristband
doing all that weird [ __ ] in that video
they were like well more alien [ __ ] time
to go to work but that is where I
believe Kamala Khan's bracelets could
come from in the MCU let us know what
you guys think in the comment section
below but thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
Master retainment on Twitter if you want
to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but more
importantly you can follow Newark series
wherever we are on social media but make
sure to hit that Bell at the bottom of
this video so you can get notifications
every time we upload a video and of
course make sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to buy it our newest
latest Obsession shirt inspired by both
Obi-Wan Kenobi and Miss Marvel they're
not gonna last forever so pick one up
today but again I love you guys so much
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you